bonjour que de ganay oui bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france on va parler de ce rapport
qu est ce que ça nous apprend
concrètement aujourd'hui il y en a
effectivement régulièrement il y aurait
moins de détenus a radicalisé en prison
aujourd'hui
à écouter non moi il ya beaucoup de
détenus radicaliser qui vont sortir dans
les trois ans qui viennent et ce qui
nous préoccupe et c'est pour ça qu'on
les arts qu'on l'a signalé dans notre
rapport annuel de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
nous avons en nous avions au début de
l'année de cette année nous recensions
environ 470 détenus
classée terroriste islamiste et auquel
on vivre on peut rajouter environ 700
détenus
radicaliser parmi ceux-ci donc environ
163 pour sortir c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure avec un rythme
d'une soixantaine par an à peu près et
c'est cela qui nous préoccupe c'est là
nous souhaitons attirer l'attention des
pouvoirs publics et de l'ensemble de la
communauté du renseignement sur c'est
les risques potentiels de ces détenus ce
mot ce qu'il y à un suivi particulier
qui est prévue aujourd'hui pour suivre
ces profils à leur sortie de prison
alors si vous voulez on a renforcé petit
à petit bien sûr avec lassitude l'état
d'urgence ensuite qui a été remplacé par
une loi enfin système de ses lectures
sécurité intérieure et de lutte contre
le terrorisme qu'on appelle site qui a
renforcé les mesures de surveillance de
tous les détenus qui sans de prison et
radicaliser alors on a on a eu un savon
de difficultés parce que bien sûr on est
dans une démocratie dont conçu
l'ensemble de ces mesures sont soumises
certains contrôles par exemple il ya eu
un allongement de ce conte une mesure
qui était intéressante qui s'appelle une
mesure de
l'administratif de surveillance cos mika
pour les sortants de prison condamné on
avait on avait souhaité que ça soit
allonger la durée qui est puisque ce
petit positif existait depuis 2015 on a
souhaité qu'il soit
tendu par deux ans
le grand c quantifier les à censurer et
à considérer qu'on devait maintenir plus
de cela des billets donc on a un certain
nombre de mesures mais on a du mal à
aller faire c'est ma position
personnelle à les faire appliquer voilà
c'est une surveillance qui commence
évidemment en prison avec ses fameux
quartier d'évaluation de la
radicalisation on apprend que pour la
première fois un quartier d'évaluation
de ce type est ouvert à rennes pour les
femmes
afren il va y avoir un quartier à
fresnes donc pour l'instant c'est un
nombre assez réduit froides chez lui
place d'ici la fin de l'année bon donc
effectivement il ya ses quartiers à la
fois des validations la radicalisation
et puis de prise en charge et la
radicalisation qui ont été créés ou qui
vont l'être dans les différentes prisons
et notamment celles qui sont dédiées aux
femmes actuellement écho kae lequel
résultats concrètement on obtient grâce
à ces grâce à ces quartiers d'évaluation
avec n'obtient déjà donc un suivi
par par l'ensemble des services
pénitenciers qui suit ça attentivement
on a il existe un service de
renseignement pénitencier que vous le
savez et celui ci est en fort retrait
parfait moyen
à la fois financier et en termes
d'objectifs et contrôler et encadre
cesser ces détenus il ya aussi une autre
inquiétude des parlementaires relayée
dans ce rapport sont les personnes
retenues dans les camps syrie qu'en est
il va effectivement il ya eu on le voit
bien qu'il ya une dégradation
significative
dans cette zone de dirac irako syrienne
et donc il le nombre de deux de ces
détenus
emprisonnés une sur place peut
représenter une proie
intéressante pour bêche bon donc nous on
attire l'attention également sur ceux de
ses 7,7 inquiétude parce que
ils sont potentiellement des futurs bon
ben
voilà petit petit pont et projeté en
europe et en france en particulier de ce
qu'il vaut mieux pas trier pour pouvoir
mieux les surveiller
alors non police alors il ya toute la
sita situation et vous faites allusion
aussi à l'article récent du monde une
tribune mais vous payez d'une part les
hommes que nous nous considérons que ce
qu'ils ont été quand été confondus comme
terroriste soit jugé sur place à cette
position majoritaire je dirais en tout
cas et puis pour les femmes c'est les
enfants et les mères dans ce qu'on
considère que c'est vraiment un souci si
je suis bien encadré
parce que
l on était en flammes étaient également
très conditionné merci beaucoup claude
de ganay pour votre éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
député à l'ère du loiret membres de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement